hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
today we're going to be talking about an
interesting take on ethics and morality
on a societal or even global level but
not talking with a philosopher talking
with economist Tyler Cowen Tyler is well
known among people who read the Internet
he's an accomplished economist and
author also the host of his own podcast
called conversations with Tyler but
perhaps if you are an internet person
you know him best for his extremely
successful blog marginal revolution that
he runs with his colleague George Mason
University Alex Tabarrok Tyler has very
distinctive style on the blog it's pithy
and provocative and he specializes in
turning an economists eye to a wide
variety of issues from things like
global trade that you would expect
economists to write about to how to
enjoy music or read books or what to
order in a restaurant when you go to
visit a foreign city this kind of
perspective is very very useful and
Tyler now turns his perspective in a new
book called stubborn attachments to the
question of how we should act as a
society so as to be good
consequentialists he's not a firm
consequentialist when it comes to
morality some of you may know that to
grate competing schools of morality or
ethics are consequentialism that says
there's some act that you do and whether
your act is moral or not depends on what
its consequences are typically you're
kind of a utilitarian you want to
increase the greatest good for the
greatest number or some other measure of
utility aggregated over people
I suppose the day intelligence who have
rules that they follow and it's not the
consequences that matter it's the rules
themselves so in his new book Tyler says
if you're a good consequentialist and
you want to sort of increase the
greatest good for the greatest number
it's not just people today that matter
it's future generations that matter just
as much and so if you believe that it's
a arguable assumption of course you
could typically discount the future
generations because you don't know as
much about them but he says there's no
good reason to do that and if that's
true then what we know from empirical
studies is that if you have economic
growth
now then eventually everybody benefits
economic growth now doesn't benefit
everybody today it's unequally spread in
its benefits but ultimately if the whole
society is doing better economically
then generally almost everyone gets
better off and therefore if you care
about future generations the moral thing
to do is to work to increase economic
growth today now you can argue with this
and of course it's not quite that naive
if you concentrate on short-term
economic growth and destroy the planet
then you haven't increased anybody's
utility so you have to be careful about
those kinds of risks that you'd be
taking and so these are the issues that
we'll be talking about on the podcast
today in a very wide-ranging
conversation I do want to apologize a
little bit both to listeners and to
Tyler because I mixed up the date when
we were supposed to have our
conversation as a result I was less
prepared than usual and we also had text
problems we couldn't use Zen caster
which I usually use we used Skype so the
audio quality is not what it what it
could be so Tyler was great the
conversation is extremely useful but I
wasn't quite ready myself to dig in as
deeply as I would really like
nevertheless it's that still does you
know compared to what I wanted it to be
the conversation turned out great
overall there's a lot of food for
thought you may or may not agree with it
but it's it does what good sort of
thought experiment philosophy economics
and so forth should do it pushes your
brain in directions that it might not
usually go and there's a detour at the
end of the conversation into the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics which I'm sure everyone will
like so with that in mind let's go
[Music]
Tyler Cowen welcome to the blind skate
podcast thank you for having me
so I wanted to start with sort of a
higher level meta question you're an
economist of course but not just that
you've written some books about you know
how do you think like an economist how
to order lunch like an economist how
important is that being an economist to
how you think about yourself well it's a
lens through which you see the entire
world so I think in general too many
academics they segregate their research
from their lives and they treat them as
two separate things but if you're going
to do economics or philosophy or
political science you want to realize
you know you should live what you preach
in some sense so I think that's been an
important part of what I've tried to do
in my life so what does it mean that in
your mind to think like an economist or
to live your life like an economist that
when you see a situation you try to ask
why did this come about is this the
result of some kind of more
generalizable model you ask what here
are the preferences and the constraints
what are the incentives facing the
individuals just some very basic
categories you start applying you
throughout with them at the problem so
you go to restaurants and whatever they
have only three dishes on the menu the
food is really good and you wonder well
why might that be that's thinking like
an economist well I mean I I that was
more or less the kind of answer I expect
you to give and I think it's interesting
because probably if you talk to people
on the street and ask them what how
economists think you would hear words
like money and finance and budgets and
none of those words appeared in what you
just said money it's only one thing that
people value we also value respect
recognition love friendship so a typical
economic question if you're sitting in a
movie and you're bored should you walk
it maybe because you've already paid for
the ticket you're not getting that money
back it's a sunk cost so basically you
should go so basically economics is a
way of being a rational person sort of
fulfilling your desires in terms of your
maximizing your actions to get whatever
incentives whatever desires you have
or sometimes it's the way of
understanding why you're not a rational
person so we're never going to approach
that model and maybe we shouldn't kick
ourselves too hard for that but again
it's just organizing categories to put
your thoughts into and help you see you
know patterns across different decisions
right I mean economics is an interesting
situation sort of visa via the public
imagination you know it's a high-status
occupation in many ways compared to
theoretical physics which is what I do
which is in different ways a high-status
occupation but economists have a lot
more relationship with policy or
business or things like that and they
get criticism for things like you know
imagining that people are more rational
than they really are or being more
interested in the bottom line than in
more less tangible values what do you
say to people who have those critiques
in the back of their minds many of those
critiques are correct
economics is part science but it's also
part art and maybe a lot of people are
two-thirds rational maybe the most
rational people are those who have a lot
of money on the line so that gives
economics some predictive power but you
need to approach it with epistemic
humility and you know most people did
not predict the financial crisis or the
Great Depression for that matter and you
know it's not a forecasting science it
helps you see patterns but it's also not
the only way you can see more patterns
that's an interesting thing you just
mentioned about people being more
rational with more money on the line I
can certainly understand why that might
be the case do we have evidence that
that's actually true there's a Chicago
economist named John list and he did a
study of people trading baseball cards
so a few of people trading the cards who
are not used to doing this once they own
the card they value it as much more just
because it's there it's like they
identify with the card it's mine but
professional traders are in a sense more
ruthless they're more willing to just
buy and sell at whatever is the best
price and this kind of result has been
replicated a number of other times so it
does seem to be true that professionals
with money on the line they're closer to
at leaf and closer to at least a naive
economic conception of
shanell maximizing behavior interesting
is this related to the fact that you
know if you're shopping for a house and
you put a bid in on a house and someone
bids it at more than you're willing to
spend so you lose it you're very sad
even though technically speaking you
should not be sad that you you know used
to be more or less indifferent to paying
exactly the amount that you would value
the house act correct and under some
assumptions you should be sad when you
win the house because that means you
have winners curse you are the highest
bidder you're the one who overestimated
what it's worth more than any of the
other people and what is it so how do we
bring that to the lunch table what does
it mean to go into a restaurant and eat
like an economist you need to figure out
who in the restaurant can you actually
ask what is the best dish will they take
you seriously how do you establish your
credibility if you just walk into a
Chinese restaurant and say what's the
best dish they'll actually serve you the
worst one they might approach you with a
certain amount of contempt but if you
tell them you've like been to regional
Chinese cities and talk about different
regional cuisines get their attention
they're more willing to help so it's the
question of learning how to communicate
it's as much sociology as economics
getting back to the limitations of
economics and being a good judge of
people is worth at least as much as
knowing a lot about food I would say
because the key question is whom to ask
right now that's a very good point I do
so I disagreed or I had questions about
one of the points you made in one of
those books I forget which one it was
but about the specials on the menu I
believe that you made the point that if
you look at a menu and something is in a
box and it looks like they're trying to
push it that's the thing you should not
order is that correct on average there
are exceptions but at least your initial
instinct should be to shy away from it
and what's the rationale behind that if
they have a special often it's something
they're not used to making if it's one
of their best dishes you wonder why
isn't it just on the menu sometimes
they're just trying to get rid of the
stock left in the kitchen there are a
lot of reasons to be wary of specials in
particular cases say well something is
in season truffles a certain kind of
mushroom then maybe take it more
seriously but it could just be an
experiment
and you're the guinea pig and well and
maybe you value that that would be okay
if you're that kind of person right do
you like being a guinea pig sometimes
you like stories like really really bad
restaurants can be the best meals of all
for that reason right right that's true
horror movies and so forth yes did you
yes would you say that you've always
thought like an economist more or less
and you just become more professional
about it as you've grown up or is it
something you discovered along the way
when I was very young
say 10 11 years old I was a chess player
and then I thought like a chess player
which is not totally unlike thinking
like an economist but chess players they
learn how to calculator and think things
through many steps they also learn very
early on a lot of their decisions are
wrong
that's good training for doing many
things so first I thought like a chess
player then by age 14 I started thinking
like an economist and philosopher and
then I've just worked on building that
up and in some ways trying to cure
myself of thinking like an economist and
think more like a sociologist well
that's an interesting point because I've
always wondered about the fact that as
professors as academics we're forced to
choose our specialty fairly early in
life right I mean what are the chances
that you're gonna figure out when you're
15 or 15 years old what what you should
be doing for a living are you happy with
the choices you made along those lines
oh very much so but again as you're a
professor there's this dangerous poison
you're used to telling people things and
being a kind of authority and you need
to get out of that mindset by having all
kinds of obstreperous friends who tell
you you're you know full of crap and you
need to keep balance because there are
so many incentives toward thinking
you're right and not so many toward
realizing you're wrong a lot have you
been successful at having a stripper's
friends who tell you full of crap it's
not for me to judge you'd have to ask my
obstreperous friends like how
obstreperous are they really because a
lot of people think they do this and
it's part of the mindset of thinking oh
I've succeeded at everything including
having obstreperous friends so only the
friends know for sure what where do you
where would you say this probably unfair
question but do you think academics err
too much on agreeing with each other or
disagreeing with each other there's
incentives for both in some sense
there's way too much conformity bias
in social sciences at least people who
just kind of show up at the lunch table
they talk about local politics or small
talk they more or less assume they agree
with each other they don't think all
that carefully about a lot of their
views they don't integrate it with what
they know about economics and they just
kind of sleepwalk through through
intellectual life in some ways right
don't read that much outside their
fields well good so I was gonna say
other than the obstreperous friends
what is the toolkit what are the what
are the things we can do to try to be
awakened from our dogmatic slumbers do
you think well if you're a professor try
to hire really good colleagues my school
has done a great job at that some of my
obstreperous friends are my colleagues
but also have a good relationship with
your family they're not exactly your
friends but typically they are people
willing to tell you when you're screwing
up in different ways so cultivate those
connections in ways that also help your
career and not just your family life and
always confront yourself with reminders
of like your own mortality that like
what you think is important in a given
moment is not a very reliable indicator
write as much of that as you can I try
to hang art on the walls of my home
actually to remind myself of my own
mortality that's good yeah and you
mentioned sociology as something maybe
that you're learning more about or
trying to think more like and but
philosophy certainly shows up a lot in
the new book is that a professional
interest in philosophy or is it just
something you can't avoid if you try to
do economics both you can't avoid it
when I was 14 years old I thought I
might even become a philosopher
prudence took hold it's much harder to
get a good job that way but philosophy
for me is an interest almost as great as
economics and this new book stubborn
attachments it's an attempt to outline
the philosophical foundations of our
economic judgments like why is
capitalism good why our rational choice
is justifiable at all so I have to
confess I'm going to ask you the most
obvious question what are the
attachments that we are stubbornly
attached to that you refer to in the
title of the new book
well I argue we should be stubbornly
attached to the idea of economic growth
okay compounding returns
it is more powerful than any other
utilitarian factor in boosting human
well-being
and the other thing we should be
stubbornly attached to is Human Rights
which in some instances are absolute you
simply should not violate people's
rights no matter what and those you know
two blades economic growth in human
rights if we follow those and we're all
stubbornly attached to them things will
just turn that wonderful and not really
so much pursue other values right at the
macro level you know I thought I can say
I think I really enjoyed the book by the
way and you know it's very short I
encourage listeners to read it it's a
set of big ideas that I hadn't quite
come across before and it's one of those
books we'll do you agree with it or not
it's worth taking seriously can I ask
you do you how much of your intention
when writing a book like this is to
provoke people to think differently in
addition to saying things that are true
somewhat but the main intention in any
book I write is to provoke myself to
figure out what I think at all so
they're like unsolved problems in my
mind and I only work them out by writing
about them so it's a very selfish
endeavor maybe I should have the reader
more in mind but I don't it's not so
much a didactic purpose but more
directed toward me yeah I don't know I
mean I I feel the same way and it's also
with the podcast I know that you're also
a podcaster I mean my personal
podcasting goal is to have conversations
that I enjoy do you find that not only
for books but for your wider
communicative strategy sure you know my
podcasts conversations with Tyler it's
called I'm not paid to do them even
indirectly I don't think they earn me
any money so I better enjoy it but the
main reason I do it is partly to ask
people questions but it's also to focus
my own reading rights so fun stuff like
all crude matter Larry Summers or Kareem
abdul-jabbar I learned so much reading
about them so it's the improvement in my
thinking before the podcast ever happens
that's the biggest gain for me exactly I
definitely find the same thing and so I
think you know we have the time here I
want to really dig into the
philosophical presuppositions in the new
book you so you mentioned on there's a
sort of consequentialist aspect to how
your
you know we should do things to get some
large good but but you're not a pure
consequentialist you want to soften that
a little bit with some rules some rights
I mean how specific can you be about how
we mix this goal of being utilitarian or
consequentialist with human rights or
other rule-based dant illogical
guidelines most of my book is about the
consequentialism and I think I say in
the preface on something like a 2/3
you'd blitek
usually consequences are the thing that
matters but you know should we slaughter
large numbers of innocent babies just to
boost GDP a bit I definitely want to say
now so I'm carving out for the reader a
kind of protected sphere these are the
things we shouldn't do and then the
space of what's left I'm trying to
figure out what's best and I again I
keep on coming back to this idea of
compounding returns right if you can get
compounding returns you're probably
doing the right thing I'd say that's the
core point of the book on the practical
issues and also with your own education
your own knowledge like are you learning
in some kind of compounding way over
time if you're not you're probably not
getting very far right now I want to get
into compound returns in detail but I
think that there's this prior claim
which I thought to be you know the most
substantial one that you think that we
discount the future consequences too
much I mean I know that economists
professionally discount future
predictions a little bit but as
utilitarians people often try to get the
greatest good for the greatest number of
people alive right now and you're saying
people alive 100 generations from now
should count for almost as much is that
right once they arrive they are no less
real so imagine that Cleopatra several
thousand years ago had decided she would
take an extra helping of desert knowing
that this would lead to the death of
3,000 people today I mean discounting
could in principle justify a decision
like that but I think that's
indefensible so that you know as
individuals we often discount out of
weakness like oh I'll go to the dentist
another week later but at the societal
level to really care about the future
and our descendants and make decisions
to reflect that including science
climate change the rate of saving
how much we innovate we're missing up
we're myopic and there's plenty of
laboratory evidence that human beings
can be very myopic so so let me just get
it exactly the substantive claim though
should we when we add zero or just count
them at zero okay that's good that's a
very specific number
now you discount for risk if you're not
sure something will happen you down
weighted accordingly but you don't
discount it just because it's further
away in time okay
and what do you say to the various you
know suggested puzzles that utilitarian
approaches get themselves into you know
if every life is worth a little bit and
you're not discounting the future at all
should everybody just have as many
babies as they possibly could you know
or the the repugnant conclusion I'm sure
you're familiar with it you have
strategies to get out of these I do
think we should aim for institutions
that encourage people to have more
children subsidizing education is one
way of doing that making sure that
living in major American cities or say
London is affordable is another way of
doing that and the fact that these
policies can sustainably support more
people is a reason to do them I don't
think you simply want to boost numbers
for their own sake you want people to
want to have the children to raise them
properly that's more likely to boost
economic growth than trying to make the
whole world you know like some kind of
teeming slum but absolutely the numbers
should count and the richer we are the
more people will be able to support with
our resources right okay so is there a
principled defence of heavy discounting
I mean I know people take it for granted
and you're saying you shouldn't discount
at all is what is the counter-argument
what are people saying that you know we
shouldn't care about five generations in
the future nearly as much as today
well people sometimes confuse the
perspective of a corporation with that
of all of society so fewer corporation
and you're doing budgeting and you're
calculating and monetary terms for a lot
of purposes you should use various kinds
of discount rates that is not incorrect
but if you're talking about happiness or
well-being and all of society for the
distance
future affecting entire lives that's
when we should apply the zero rate of
discount so most of the criticisms I
think comes from people confusing the
corporate case with the societal case is
it fair I had the image as I want to see
if you agree with it or not while
reading the book of you being the
temporal version of Peter Singer right
singer has may decide to make the case
where you should care about a life of a
person thousands of miles away who
you've never met just as much as a
person you see drowning in a lake
because that is that
analogous to what you're saying about
future generations correct and I once
interviewed singer it's on on blogging
heads TV and I found him very
short-sighted it's all about
redistributing wealth now mmm rather
than increasing the size of the pie and
the human race over time okay that's the
wrong perspective I want to increase the
size of the pie which also means you can
afford more redistribution I might add
right so you think that he's he's
figured it out with respect to space but
not yet with respect to time I hope I
have had influence on him I am not so
sure okay that's very good okay so
that's the the sort of well let me and I
guess I'm not quite satisfied with my
own personal understanding of the
balance I already mentioned between the
utilitarian part of things and the
ontological part of things so you invent
a concept called wealth plus could you
explain that wealth plus is similar to
what we today called GDP but there's
some problems in GDP it doesn't properly
account for the value of the environment
and it doesn't properly account for the
value of leisure time so I just want to
adjust GDP a bit to make it a finer
measure that's wealth plus basically and
over time a much richer society is going
to be much happier much better off more
creative more rewarding than a much
poorer society even if it's not at first
if you look at countries that have say a
third or the fifth of the per capita
income of America I mean they're really
much worse places to live and you see
this in terms of where people want to
migrate and as well and one of the nice
things about GDP is it's very
quantifiable who do you think there's a
equally precise even if not accurate
formula for wealth plus I sure it can be
to measure the value of the environment
leisure time it's pretty easy to measure
the value of but you know let's come as
close as we can and for the most part
actually wealthier societies are also
cleaner not in every regard not with
respect to carbon but for the most part
regular wealth and environmental quality
they actually moved together try
visiting a really poor country if you
want to demonstrate that point to
yourself right so the imperfections of
measurements I'm not sure they're
actually the main problem it's getting
people to want to do it okay
and then we but we don't simply maximize
wealth plus there are also rights that
we won't trample on in order to do that
is it right do you how clearly
delineated are those rights or are you
just happy at this point to say we're
sure there are rights we can talk about
them the ladder like I said the rights
are not the main focus of my book I
think it's worth people spending much
more time talking about that but if
someone says well I want to maximize
something I'm gonna force every woman to
have nine children I would say that's a
violation of Rights let's look at ways
of subsidizing societies so they become
wealthier to support more people and
more resources right I mean in some
sense I would associate daily
ontological approaches more with a kind
of libertarian political outlook in the
sense that let people do what they want
and let the consequences fall where they
may
but are you sort of being a libertarian
consequentialist is that a is that a
thing that exists it exists there I
would say that's very close to my view
you could say I'm a smaller libertarian
but I don't think taxation is
intrinsically evil I think there are a
lot of public goods which governments
you're actively supply in some cases
such as infrastructure or subsidizing
science I don't think we're doing enough
right now but our governments are very
bad at many things like say running the
New York City subway and we also need to
liberate private enterprise more but
government in the market they're not
always substitutes you want to look for
policies that actually boost both of
them at the same time right okay so if
we buy the idea that conventional
approaches discount future generations
far too much your second big idea you
bring in is that the best way maybe well
maybe I'll exaggerate this and you can
correct me the best way to help the
future generations is to maximize our
rate of economic growth right now is
that right correct and to hand down to
them high quality institutions which
will help them maximize their rate of
economic growth so you want
sustainability of the growth that's why
the environment is supporting is
important because a bad environment can
threaten sustainability so it's like
expected value looking forward and is
there is there's a few of a society
growing sorry say it 3% over time over a
hundred two hundred years that will be
much much wealthier than a society
growing at 2% right and that's the
miracle again that's due to compounding
yeah exactly right and is this I mean is
it is this what can I say the claim is
that if you have lots of economic growth
more or less everyone benefits right
it's not just you know we could imagine
in principle economic growth we're a
tiny slice of people benefited a lot and
a lot of people didn't but empirically
that doesn't seem to be the case is that
what was on in the back of our minds
here over time virtually everyone
benefits in the first year not everyone
benefits a lot of people are thrown out
of work all kinds of problems which you
can see on the evening news any night
but if you look at countries that devote
themselves to economic growth such as
South Korea or Japan and you look at
where they are now compared to say the
seventy eighty years ago I absolutely
think it's correct that virtually
everyone is better off but not in the
given year right clearly not people get
upset yeah and is that so what is the
theoretical or empirical argument as to
why that is the case I mean we should if
this is gonna be a major policy driver
we should try to understand why it is
true that everyone benefits rather than
some nightmare where one person gets all
the wealth and everyone else suffers
humans can do things with resources they
want to produce for other humans sell
things to other human beings economic
growth is exactly that process of
figuring out which good
and services other people want and if
you have more of it over time again real
incomes will rise wages will rise people
will take better more rewarding and
safer jobs and left more choice as to
you know whom to marry healthcare will
be better education will be better
there'll be less infant mortality some
of the angles of our lives become a lot
better well what is the connection
between having more choices about who to
marry and economic growth well say you
have an agricultural society it's poor
everyone lives in a small village
you're not very mobile you don't have
railways odds are you'll marry someone
right in your village you know if you're
gay probably there's less toleration
being gay than there is in most
countries today and you might marry
someone of the opposite gender and not
actually want to do that pretty common
in human history and capitalism has
eased a lot of those constraints okay so
the argument is something like there's a
kind of cosmopolitanism or even sort of
a liberalism of values that goes along
with increased economic prosperity and
it will over time make virtually
everyone happy maybe not misanthropes
right so I don't think you can say
everyone is better off but if the
misanthrope soar the main problem I feel
things are looking pretty good for
economic growth well so what so how do
you think about cases like China for
example where they're getting a lot of
economic growth with less political or
social liberties than we have here do
you think that that's it going to be a
temporary condition and the greater
prosperity will lead to greater
liberalization or or is it just the
price we pay there's a common pattern in
other East Asian economies you see it in
Taiwan you see it somewhat in Singapore
you see it in South Korea also Japan
that at some point of wealth people
demand democracy and it's given to them
now China is about arriving at that
point it's not clear they will actually
democratize I very much believe it would
be better if they did I don't think
China should have been a democracy all
along
it probably would not have been stable
so I think the Communist Party has
actually
pretty remarkable job there and we
should credit them for that but it's a
tyrannical also somewhat inefficient
institution and it needs to reform and
evolve into something much better as say
Taiwan has done we'll see if it happens
it's not guaranteed no right it's not
guaranteed I'm sure that their arguments
back and forth such just interested in
your perspective I mean one person might
say with greater economic prosperity
comes more resources people can talk to
each other they can share ideas they can
at their they're going to demand more
say in how the country is run someone
more pessimistic might say that you know
we have technologies and and means of
control now that might make repressive
autocracy more stable you know what
harder to rebell against do you have
feelings about this the wealthy Western
democracies so far have been quite
stable as democracies I don't see any of
them evolving into the Chinese model the
Chinese model arguably is becoming less
stable power is more centralized in
China than it was even a few years ago
all that ability to have surveillance I
think will prove destabilizing rather
than a good thing for them the idea is
you give everyone a social credit score
and get complete cooperation right I
don't think they'll be able to make that
work so I mean there is a kind of
competition of systems going on not only
do I favor the capitalist democracies
but I would be willing to bet on them
and in a sense I have with my life
choices right so what is it was it come
down to in terms of straightforward
policy prescriptions right now what are
the what are the things that our country
should do to maximize economic growth as
opposed to some of the alternatives we
should regulate most of our economy much
less but that said many parts of the
environment we should be tougher with
regulations we should spend more money
subsidizing science in some cases build
more infrastructure and simply
culturally move to a situation where
it's possible say to build the Golden
Gate Bridge in three years as we once
did to build the Empire State Building
as quickly as we did to put a man on the
basically seven years starting from
scratch we've lost a lot of those
capabilities it can take us decades just
do like extend one subway line in
Manhattan so some of it is we need a
cultural shift but those would be some
of the policies I would change I mean
why is that why does it take us so long
to fix the subway Manhattan I'm in Los
Angeles where we're not as we're no
better in terms of new subway lines but
at least New York has much better you
think you've done a much better job than
any other American city still poor by
Chinese standards I might add there are
so many overlapping authorities that
have to give a go-ahead for the New York
City subway right it can be labor unions
it can be New York State
Port Authority different commissions and
getting them all in sync and the public
and how you pay for it just takes a long
long time and we're like way past an
optimal point on that curve do you think
this is just a sort of natural human
inclination to the love of bureaucracy
you know once you have things that are
institutions that have existed for a
very long time people write rules and
implement them even though they no
longer really applicable
yes that's natural but even within the
u.s. some places are much better and
worse than others so don't think that
what we have is inevitable and cannot be
changed it can be changed when our
country not long ago was much less
bureaucratic as well okay but how does
it so what about you to talk in the book
about the distribution of wealth
especially government governmental
mechanisms that redistribute it I might
guess although I don't remember seeing
in the book that you'd be against
something like a universal basic income
on the theory that that would help
people right now in some way but maybe
slow down economic growth long-term and
therefore it would be a net negative in
this non-discounted view I don't like
the idea of paying people not to work I
also feel it doesn't make me to say
people who are disabled or very old or
maybe they've lost their parents this is
what we should do but not do it for
everyone are the best kinds of
redistributions are those that say
educate poor children or fix up their
health or and malnutrition and those
also boost wealth
so if you follow the Loadstar of
boosting wealth you'll be led toward the
better rather than the worst three
distributions okay so it's not that we
should be afraid of redistribution in
general but you want to give people the
tools to make better lives for
themselves and then wealth will increase
across the board that's right but I'm
way less enthusiastic about just taking
money from rich people and giving it to
poor if the incentive on both sides is
to work less and create less then I
generally don't want to do it I would
just say stick with wealth enhancing
redistribution there's plenty of that we
can do it's very powerful do you have
feelings about the level of inequality
in the u.s. today or is it level of
inequality irrelevant and it's more
about incentives towards wealth creation
I look more at incentives toward wealth
creation inequality is an ex post
measure of a big distribution I would
just say look at concrete barriers
against opportunity and there are many
for today's poor and let's take more of
them away so in that sense inequality
matters a lot but don't focus on the
distribution so if rich people get
richer and the poor people are no worse
off to me that's fine right yeah there's
certainly other people who disagree with
that but I get I I think I'm on your
side yeah so you'd be very much in favor
of you know better education especially
for poor people but or maybe a better
health care also to get people out of
the risky times early in life and then
so everyone can grow up more or less
healthy and well-educated and try to
make a wealthier country air pollution
led in the water to me these are very
big issues even in the US certainly for
the world as a whole to give them far
too little attention actually which is
remarkable so we should reorient our
thinking on redistribution to the most
effective kinds so you said more support
for scientific research I'm not going to
argue with that but what about more
support for other kinds of intellectual
endeavors whether it's you know
humanities or arts or other things too
how do those factor into wealth creation
I would put it this way we're not sure
always have the arts and humanities
factored in to wealth creation it's not
as clear-cut as science the system we
have now is we have state universities
which indirectly support those a lot and
States
Pete with different systems and when
we're not sure what's exactly the best
thing to do then I'm keener to have
federalism and these competing
experiments so I like the idea that our
universities if their public sector
they're done by the states and not by
the federal government especially for
the arts and humanities so I would say I
don't know the right answer and when you
don't know that's the way to approach it
and how do we how do we fit the goal of
increasing human rights into this you
know over history we I think we can
argue that we've increased human rights
at least in the subset of liberal
democracies and so forth do you think
that just comes along for the ride when
we increase wealth or is this something
we should be separately agitating for or
those not really competing ideals they
mostly move together but not in all
cases in the United States our rate of
incarceration is disgracefully high
mm-hmm and even though we're much
wealthier that doesn't seem to have
stopped it in some ways it helps us
afford it so I feel we should take
dramatic action to say limit or end the
war on drugs change the incentives of
public prosecutors so they're not always
trying to ask for higher and higher
sentences that voters need to not always
just sleep the candidate candidates who
claim they're tough on crime that to me
is probably the biggest violation of
human rights in our country right now
right will be our penal system yeah but
again a lot of the people are guilty
just to be clear but they don't deserve
the treatment they get in most cases
right and they're guilty of breaking
laws that we made up right they're just
a lot of them are just genuinely guilty
of real crimes but still the idea that
because you committed armed robbery
three times you have to join a gang and
maybe you'll be gang raped in the shower
and you'll have this horrible existence
that to me is not right is that do you
have an explanation in mind as to why
the United States is so different from
its fellow liberal democracies in that
aspect I think we have a much more
violent history where firearms were
intimately connected to settling and
painting this nation and we have stayed
in that culture
and then we're just very diverse and
we're a very large country and we don't
have always very strong pressures for
social conformity so the upside is we
have more creativity but also a lot more
people behaving in crazy destructive
ways and I don't really have like a big
picture fix for that
right so let me ask I'm gonna shift
gears here a little bit back to the idea
of not discounting future generations as
a cosmologists about the whole history
of the universe I have in mind we're
integrating all of the wealth plus or
whatever other measure we have over the
course of many many many years and I get
the argument that due to compound
returns if the rate of growth is a
little bit bigger now that has huge
effects in the future another thing that
would have huge effects in the future is
you know the end of civilization right
if we ruin the planet or something like
that is right is this fits in with your
philosophy I guess is why you keep
bringing up the environment presumably
the prospect of truly disastrous climate
change if that is something that could
happen would be something that in your
philosophy we should work very hard to
avoid right yes also we should spend
more say on asteroid defense or at least
developing those capabilities and other
way as a cosmologists I can just
interject it's most likely the best
theory of the universe that string
theory is it something else is it many
worlds quantum mechanics what's your
opinion oh I have very strong opinions
about this so it depends on the detailed
definition you have a theory of the
universe I am a strong proponent of the
many-worlds interpretation of quantum
mechanics I think it's by far the
simplest I can even give the sales pitch
for that if you want very briefly but
that's a framework right it's not a
specific theory the we still need to
understand what the laws of physics are
that push the wave function of the
universe forward even once you've given
me many worlds so you could be a string
theorist and believe in right worlds or
not I used to be pretty optimistic about
string theory these days I'm less so for
a number of reasons and I'm
or I'm more thinking that we just need
to not take something like strings and
quantize them we need to look at quantum
mechanics from the start and find
gravity and space-time and the universe
within it if that makes it what makes
the many worlds different universes is
it that they're branching based on
quantum states yeah exactly you know if
so that's the number of worlds rise very
rapidly it rises very rapidly it's time
passes yep it rises very rapidly and
it's every time that a quantum system
that is in superposition becomes
entangled with its environment the
universe branches and that happens a lot
it's still nowhere near so many
universes we have to worry about running
out there even if it's a finite number
we can estimate the total number of
universes we're allowed to have it's way
bigger than the number of branching
events that have occurred set me
straight on my worry that if we apply in
anthropic principle does this continual
increase of branches mean we're very
very close to the end of the universe as
we know it or the multiverse no I you
know in some reasonable measures were
halfway in some sense we will your your
intuition is right if we keep on
branching there is a limit past which
branching ceases to make sense it's very
very much like the growth of entropy in
a system so if you start very orderly
and you let entropy go it will increase
as eventually would hit equilibrium and
equilibrium means entropy can't grow
anymore likewise there will be a place
when branching can't happen anymore but
it's going to be very far in the future
but all and we likely to be living in
the most branched universe maximum
branching because we could be in any
number of different world states so
we're probably in a very densely
populated part of the multiverse with a
lot of branches and that means it's
pretty close to the end or is that wrong
no I think I'm not telling you it's
right now I get it I think that there is
a reasonable anthropic argument as you
imply that universes like ours should be
dense in the space of universes but this
is a very interesting question that that
intentionally or not
exactly back to this temporal discussion
we're having is it in any sense
reasonable to say that we live at a
typical time in the history of the
universe and I think the answer there is
no exactly because we're so far away
from equilibrium you know you can I
think you can make an argument that you
live in a typical place or time if
things around you look more or less the
same but in space things look more or
less the same from-from megaparsec to
megaparsec but in time the universe is
evolving very rapidly so we're sort of
just by evidence we have no reason to
think that we live in a typical time in
the history of the universe and do you
think physical space is infinite in the
universe we have I am NOT the multiverse
but you get what I'm asking right
yeah the observable universe is
absolutely finite and the our best
theory says it will remain finite there
is a horizon that has a fixed size and
we'll never be able to see beyond it
there are deep questions about whether
or not there is any such thing as what
is outside that horizon or not which we
don't know the answer to yeah there's a
whole literature on infinite ethics how
do you do ethics if the number of people
is infinity I suspect it's simply not
tractable but I've been reading more in
this lately ya know I'm thinking along
the same lines which is why you know
it's part of why I asked this question
you know how if you do take us a posit
that future generations count just as
much as current ones don't we have to
think very deeply about the future of
consciousness and uploading in computers
and living in a simulation and the end
of the universe I mean it doesn't sort
of creating as many conscious observers
as quickly as possible just so they can
be around for as long as possible
become a very worthwhile goal I'm all
for creating more conscious observers
when you say as quickly as possible you
need to wait that for stability but I do
think it should be a goal I'm not sure
settling other planets will ever be
possible but insofar as it might be I
would favour that it also diversifies
against risk I think there's quite a
good chance you know we all won't last
another 800 years but still in like year
3 or 400 from that we can just make
things much much
better than it otherwise would be but
the idea that we're just gonna have like
a million more years to play around with
physics and the cosmos that strikes me
as unlikely I think will destroy
ourselves Millions not that long
cosmologically speaking right or even
biologically speaking but for humans for
humans is very very long we haven't yet
if you think of weapons of mass
destruction the chance there used in a
major way in any year is quite small but
just you know let enough years tick off
and at some point it will happen
absolutely so I mean it's my biggest
worry I think it's a very big worry and
also I was recently impressed upon the
danger of solar flares for destroying
our the civilization as we know it you
know solar flares happen all the time
they're not that big but they're it's
very plausible that there is a long tail
and you know once every thousand years a
solar flare comes along that would
completely wipe out the electrical grid
if that were true we would never know
because a thousand years ago there was
no electrical grid you know to to exist
so I think these existential risks are
individually far out but collectively
very worth taking into consideration
that's exactly my view and what do you
think about simulations and and
uploading brains you know do you think
that those will count just as much as
conscious feeling creatures to whom we
should give weight when we calculate
wealth plus well in a computational
sense arguably where simulations now so
I'm not sure that the distinction
between we real people well and the
simulations is well defined so if
they're conscious intelligent sentient
beings with emotions and complex lives
and goals and plans they should count a
lot of non-human animals probably should
count for more than we count them you
could dream up creatures that I'm just
not capable of understanding and I
couldn't tell you how much they should
count or not count for but in the
meantime we sort of know what we have to
work with right now but it does suggest
a strategy for maximizing something
which is work as hard as we can to
make artificially intelligent creatures
and then send them on spaceships with
the ability to self reproduce and
scatter them throughout the galaxy right
so you know we've as many we have a
bulwark against existential risks that
is as strong as we can imagine if we've
put our artificially intelligent
creatures around every star in the
galaxy
I favor trying to do this I'm not sure
how possible it would be but subsidizing
science now will get us toward that call
right it's not right before us but if we
invest much more heavily in basic
science we'll have a chance
so I favor trying to do panspermia I
would like to see also private
philanthropy get more involved
self-replicating funnyman machines
powered by different you know stars
around the galaxy you know let it rip
send biological material around with
more advanced technologies and probes
that attempt some version of
terraforming but like in the short run
we have so many problems to solve that
just mean making better science now
right right and and the solutions you're
doing the things you just listed all
which sound great like you say we don't
know the direct path to doing them so
maybe just learning some basic science
and technology is actually the best
strategy for the short term right and
getting people to respect the notion of
like doing things quickly and doing them
well like American science so
effectively did throughout most of the
20th century and not losing that culture
which is not really just a money thing
it's a mental thing it is you know in my
personal cell rate the productivity
growth yeah we're much higher than they
are right now and scientific progress
other than like tech and Moore's law it
was mostly much more rapid it wasn't a
night there's Duke it have the airplane
sorry there's I think there's two things
going on that I'm not sure their
relative magnitude one is you know with
the Manhattan Project in world war two
physicists sort of like myself got a lot
more credit than we deserve for making
the world a good place or at least
affecting the outcomes that happen in
the world and therefore we were flooded
with money and it was good we could do a
lot of research even if it didn't pay
off immediately
and that sort of gone away it's been a
while since the great physics discovery
has changed the geopolitical landscape
like that one did the other one is that
as I as I say in my book the big picture
the laws of physics underlying everyday
life have been figured out you know we
know what atoms and particles are the
discoveries that we get in fundamental
physics these days don't lead to any
technological advances the technological
advances come from higher level things
condensed matter physics biophysics
chemistry and things like that but I see
some retro aggressions like with nuclear
power which is quite green you look at
how planes
advanced airplanes in their first say 60
years compared to how they've advanced
in the last 40 to 50 years right it's a
big difference we're still flying still
flying planes basically designed in the
late 60s which no one at the time would
have thought would have been the case so
I've seen you know traffic is much worse
a lot of areas where we're discontent to
be quite mediocre and for the plane some
of it's a policy problem yeah I mean
I've wondered about the planes what is
what is it with planes is it just the
sound barrier or is it just that we
haven't tried very hard to make better
airplanes
some of it is regulatory some of it is I
just think it's a hard problem there's a
move afoot to have real eagle-eyes
supersonic transport there are sonic
boom issues I think probably we can deal
with those or just we should be more
willing to tolerate them so we should
aim for a world where you can get in
kind of a mini space shuttle and go from
New York to Tokyo in three hours
it does seem not that far away if we
choose to do it yeah I don't know if
you've ever seen the man in the high
castle series on Netflix no but I know
the book right so the the idea based on
you know the axis one world war two and
the United States is divided up between
Japan and Germany it's set in the 1960s
and all the Germans fly around on
supersonic transports as a regular
regular thing in that alternative
history that technology was developed
much more quickly sure I mean another
area where you see slowed down just
recently is life expectancy so in 2015
and 2016
in this country life expectancy fell
that's off full does that try to I
didn't know that was my beliefs
throughout earlier parts of the 20th
century now by tiny amounts but it's not
advancing there's a CDC report you can
read that that shows this and again in
say 1961 that way would have been
impossible Indy would not have been
tolerated to be like a big national
campaign to turn this around now like
even well-educated people are not aware
of this to me that's a cultural failure
and is it that's the United States or is
that developed country that's the United
States okay how other countries it's
mostly still advancing now life
expectancies hard to measure there's
ambiguities but still that it's even
possible for our CDC to measure it as
having fall in two years in a row to me
is astonishing it's a public health
issue we're not taking good care of
ourselves there are opioids and science
is not advancing fast enough to undo
those problems that's one way to put it
yeah and no one really gives a damn yeah
no that lets a we certainly spend a lot
of money on those last few weeks of our
lives right and that's a weird thing
that maybe old other cultures don't do
as much but extending the the profitable
part of our lives is something we're
less good at correct and so I think
there's a lot of ways in which we're
screwing up and could do better yeah I
mean so what do you do
how do have people reacted to the book
is that the book is out yet right is
that correct
it's not out yet it comes out October
16th also it has not been reviewed yet
early readers quite like it but
obviously they tend to be people who
already know me maybe they're not
objective but I view this book is kind
of the culmination of my thought on a
free society thinking about it actually
writing the book over a 20-year period
so it's like my most important book to
me and yeah so like I said I thought you
know the ideas in there are wonderful
and provocative and you know I remember
taking a graduate philosophy course with
John Rawls when I was at Harvard and you
know he said his goal is not that he'd
be correct but that there'd be no
mistakes in the book so what he meant
was you know there's some axioms or some
starting points and you
can disagree with that but from the
starting points you should derive the
correct conclusions and I didn't see any
obvious mistakes in your book I think
that people can probably disagree with
some of the initial starting assumptions
which is fair enough right
thank you I'll tell you what I think was
Rawls his big mistake it had to do with
economic growth he was overly enamored
of steady-state stationary state if John
Stuart Mill and he thought growth was
possibly unjust because the first
generation they were the worst off
people and to be asking them to save and
help grow the economy he worried that
might be wrong and that's very different
from my view as you know and that I
think is the weak spot and Rawls that
most people don't talk about well when
he puts us in the original position
maybe one of the things that is not
there is you're not supposed to know who
you are in the world right but maybe
maybe secretly I implied that you knew
when you are in the world and if you
imagine there's this whole future ahead
of us that we haven't been to yet then
you know maybe the decisions we made
would be different if we could make that
future better I think he should have
admitted it doesn't work across
generations and I think in his later
political liberalism he at least
implicitly more or less says this but
since you brought up Rawls I just
thought I would give you my take on it
that's perfectly fit sir brilliant
thinker and writer but I think on
economic growth he's underrating it yeah
and so I guess there's an obvious clash
you know once the book does come out
which probably just so we know will be
just before this podcast is released so
people will have a chance to read it if
they want I presume that people who are
more directly interested and focused on
human rights social justice things like
that economic justice will resist the
conclusion even if they don't you know
go through all the steps is your
response to them simply you know you're
fighting for economic justice and human
rights but it's just for future
generations just as much as us that is
absolutely my response I've tried to
write this book too you know in part
persuade people there's so much
envision of economic justice involving
the future and there's a you have a
great story so just to sort of wrap up
here I really do want you to share the
story of where the profits for this book
are gonna go there's a fellow I met in
Ethiopia I called him Yunus he was my
travel guide in lalibela which is a
famous Ethiopian city with old stone
churches and of all the people I met in
Ethiopia he struck me as maybe the
smartest and the most stable he had good
English he supports a family if his
income is really quite low I visited his
house and I pledged to send him all of
the royalties I received from this book
so I will get nothing and he will get
all of it so if you buy my book you are
helping to support yonis and his family
of 10 people including his children his
parents and to me that's a very worthy
cause I argue in the book we should be
more altruistic at the margin and think
more about like other people and that's
my chance to do something for him but
also for the future at least the future
of Ethiopia so I think I said at the
beginning I very much believe people
should live what they write and that's
part of my highly imperfect attempt to
do that I mean I can't help to be the
curmudgeonly one who asks you know and
this is not really in the tradition of
effective altruism where you know you
should spread your wealth a little bit
more widely so in some sense are you you
know setting an example just as much as
you're actually trying to help the world
with this gesture
well I'm directly helping ten people I
wouldn't say that's widely but it's more
than just one person but I view it as
good as myself as venture capitalists
you know who will steward the funds most
effectively and I'm making a bet on
Yunus because at the time I spent with
him it sounds like a good bet to me
Tyler Callen thanks so much for being on
the podcast my pleasure thank you for
your insights on physics and all the
questions my pleasure thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]